Más allá de lo que de digamos de estas
versiones encontradas lo que parece que
es fundamental es que pregotzinc no está
fuera de juego
en
Bielorrusia sino que sigue digamos de
alguna manera confrontando al kremling y
es interesante Digamos como señala o
como critica verdad el hecho de que él
fue capaz de hacer con su con su
rebelión algo que el las fuerzas armadas
rusas fueron incapaz de hacer al
comienzo de la invasión de Ucrania
verdad Más allá de digamos de de este de
este cruce de declaraciones Me parece
que la clave es que esto incrementa la
percepción de debilidad sobre Vladimir
Putin Putin pasó en menos de 24 horas de
declarar a picot sin un traidor y de
prometer castigarlo a tener que firmar
con él un acuerdo que básicamente
exonera de persecución legal a al líder
del grupo Wagner y en ese sentido el
líder del kremlin Vladimir Putin queda
en una posición en una imagen de enorme
debilidad
bueno algo que analistas están haciendo
en estos momentos es comparar este
suceso y el intento de golpe de estado
contra gorbachov en 1991 que aceleró la
caída de la unión soviética qué
similitudes y diferencias hay entre
ambos contextos se puede equiparar hay
algunas cosas en las que sin duda se
parece verdad es interesante digamos ver
cómo
a Vladimir Putin y y y
picotsin en realidad se enfrentan desde
dos posiciones muy débiles digamos que
al final les conduce a las dos a buscar
alguna clase de solución negociada y en
ese sentido a uno le recuerda también
como los golpistas en el 91 digamos
trataron de derrocar a gorbachov pero
sin contar tampoco con un soporte
suficiente Digamos como para conducir a
su derrocamiento hay digamos una serie
de diferencias y de interro también
asociados con estas diferencias la
diferencia más importante con respecto
al 91 es el tema de la movilización
Popular en el año 91 El golpe fracasó en
buena medida por la movilización Popular
que fue encabezada por borishelstein y
que de alguna manera le catapultó a
yelsing a a reemplazar muy rápidamente a
a gorbachov Al único al último líder de
de la unión soviética
en este en el caso de la de este
episodio digamos de la rebelión de
Wagner liderada por bricot sin contra
Vladimir Putin Lo cierto es que ha
habido una casi completa ausencia de
movilización popular y por otra parte es
interesante que en el caso de en el en
el caso que en el caso de yelsin y de
gorbachov yelsin se convirtió de alguna
manera en una figura que garantizó un
retiro tranquilo a gorbachov en este
caso no vemos a nadie que sea capaz de
garantizar un retiro digamos tranquilo a
Vladimir Putin si finalmente este
proceso como parece ser abre Lo que
podría ser el final de de su gobierno en
Rusia verdad no hay ninguna figura que
se encargue de reemplazarla en el poder
pero también de garantizarle una retiro
un retiro tranquilo y en ese sentido se
diferencia bastante Un poco de ese
proceso de transición digamos que
permitió que abrió la toma del poder por
yelsin que permitió una retirada digamos
cómoda para para para Michael gorbacho
verdad Bueno cómo queda Wagner realmente
es un golpe fuerte para el grupo o
veremos una reorganización en territorio
y en medios
bueno es difícil de decirlo todavía pero
es muy probable que veamos que lo que
vamos a ver es de alguna manera la
vuelta a los orígenes de Wagner verdad
hay que recordar que Wagner nació
básicamente como un producto creado por
el Gro por la inteligencia militar rusa
y que de alguna manera promocionó
paulatinamente su crecimiento para
utilizarlo como una fuerza paralela que
le permitía realizar intervenciones en
lugares como Siria o como Libia o países
africanos Y de alguna manera negar que
habían una implicación directa de la
inteligencia militar rusa Wagner cobró
una creciente autonomía con precozin
frigoxin parece que está ahora en una
posición más débil y es probable que lo
que pase Es que la inteligencia militar
rusa de nuevo tome el control
directamente de la organización y
particularmente de esas operaciones que
están en marcha no solamente en Ucrania
sino también en lugares como mal y la
República centroafricana de tal manera
que lo que probablemente vamos a ver Es
más protagonismo del guerreo de la
inteligencia militar rusa en el control
de este grupo de mercenarios verdad